Hallo.
Bitte schön.
Guten Tag.
Ja, ich bin ja Herr Apci.
Und ich bin der Diensthabender Arzt auf dieser Station.
Und ich würde gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegespräch führen.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, gerne.
Ja, okay.
Soerst möchte ich ein paar persönlichen Daten fragen.
Okay?
Ja.
Ja, wie heißen Sie?
Schmidt Müller.
Ja, Schmidt mit DT.
Ja, amen.
Ja, genau, mit DT.
Ja, okay.
Wie alt sind Sie?
65 Jahre alt.
65.
Und wann genau sind Sie geworden?
1967.
Ich hoffe, es macht noch mehr, bisschen, aber es ist nicht schlimm.
Ja, okay.
Und Tag und Monat?
Ja, 1.04.1967.
Ja, okay.
Und wie groß sind Sie, Herr Müller?
171.
Und wie viel wiegen Sie?
80.
Und Herr Müller, was für Sie sonst, was Sie beschreiben haben?
Eigentlich, ich habe chronische Lungenerkrankungen.
Ich leide unter einer COPD, aber in den letzten 3 Tagen habe ich stark gehusst
mit Leichtdruck im Brust.
Was ich bisher nicht erlebt habe, muss ich ehrlich sein.
Ich könnte es nicht nachvollziehen, ob das von den Grünerkrankungen ist,
ob ich eine Schuhe von COPD habe,
daraufhin, welches 2 Tage gewartet habe,
ich gehe mal ins Krankenhaus, lasse ich mal genau herausfinden, wer kommt das?
Ja, okay.
Herr Müller, wie ich Sie richtig verstanden habe,
Sie haben starke Husten mit Ausführforder?
Leicht Auswurf habe ich immer gehabt, aber es ist nicht so ausgeprägt.
An die Ausruf würde ich nicht sagen.
Ja, okay.
Und seit wann haben Sie diese Husten?
Als Sie gesagt, ich hatte immer auf uns zu,
aber so in dieser Maß habe ich nie gehabt
und zudem habe ich noch so einen Brustschmeißer,
das habe ich auch gesagt.
Es ist nicht nur Husten, sondern auch so einen Brustschmeißer.
Ja, okay.
Und wann fängt Ihre Brustschmerzen an?
Das ist auch vor 3 Tagen eigentlich.
Und wo genau, in der Mitte?
Gesandte Brustwand, ja.
Und wie können Sie diese Schmerzen beschreiben?
Sind Sie dumm oder drückend?
Drückende Schmerzen.
Und strahlende Schmerzen,
wohingen auf mit Rücken oder Unten?
Nein, so eine Ausstrahlung,
kann ich nicht genau sagen,
habe ich auch nicht gespürt.
Das gesamte Brustwand des Betroffenen,
ich habe so eine drückende Schmerzen,
kann ich nicht mehr sagen.
Okay.
Wie können Sie,
oder auf eine Schmerzikala,
was spricht Japan 1 bis 10,
wobei 1 sehr leite Schmerzen und 10 sehr starke Schmerzen.
Wie stark sind die Schmerzen?
Wie stark die Schmerzen sind, das ist gute Frage.
Wenn ich Husten, dann tut es noch mehr weh.
Während Husten habe ich so eine Schmerzskala
zwischen 7 und 8.
Und danach, wenn ich mich erleichtere,
wenn ich keine Husten habe,
so eine dumpfe Schmerz,
dann eher bis 4 bis 5, würde ich sagen.
Okay, Herr Müller.
Und, Herr Müller.
Ja, sind Sie Fiber oder haben Sie Ihre Fiber gemessen?
Ich habe Fiber,
vielleicht haben Sie es freutzeitig gehabt.
Ich habe es nicht aber nicht gemessen.
Mir war warm,
aber ich kann es nicht genau sagen,
dass ich ein Fiber war.
Okay.
Und, Herr Müller,
haben Sie noch andere Beschwerden?
Ja, vielleicht.
Sie haben gesagt,
Sie haben leichte Ausrufe.
Wie ist Ihre Ausrufe?
Welche warme?
Wie ist die Konsistenz?
Ich habe gesagt,
eigentlich habe ich nicht so eine ausgeprägte Ausrufe.
Ich habe eine Grunderkrankung durch die COPD.
Eigentlich war die Ausrufe immer so leicht Geld.
Ich würde sagen, es ist normal.
Natürlich sind Sie der Arzt.
Wir können das besser entscheiden.
Aber meines Erachtens ist es normal.
Okay, sehr schön.
Haben Sie das nicht bemerkt?
Ja, im Blut, im Auswurf.
Ob ich Blut im Auswurf gesehen habe?
Oder blutige Ausrufe gesehen habe?
Ja.
Ich konnte keine auf Blut feststellen.
Okay.
Haben Sie schnelle Herzschlagen?
Ob ein Herzschläge schlägt,
das ist eine gute Frage.
Ab und zu schon,
habe ich schon eine Herzschlage.
Aber nicht dauerhaft, manchmal.
Okay.
Das kommt und geht wieder weg.
Sie sind nicht mehr da oder gehen Sie wieder weg?
Ob ich dauerhaft schmeißen habe.
Ich habe nicht dauerhaft schmeißen.
Ja, ich muss sagen, er meistern schon.
Aber wenn ich schlafe, dann ist es okay.
Ich kann es normal schlafen, muss ich sagen.
Okay.
Und gibt es etwas, das sich meistens lindert oder versteht?
Ein Auslöser für die Schmälze.
Ja, gibt es eine bestimmte Auslösung?
Nee, hustern.
Ja, nicht.
Durch die Hustern vermehrt sich denn?
Ja, sind Ihre Beschwerden,
hatten sich Ihre Hustern beim Einatmen
oder beim Ausatmen versteckt oder verländert?
Ob das am Atemabhängigen ist, mein Sie?
Ja.
Ich würde es gerade nehmen.
Hustern oder Ihre Brötchenmärchen?
Schwierig zu antworten.
Ja, Ihnen würde ich sagen.
Ja, okay.
Und beim Liegen oder beim Hochlegen oder beim Stehen
haben Sie das bemerkt, irgendwelche Veränderungen?
Nein, eigentlich nicht.
Nein, nicht.
Okay.
Haben Sie Schüttefröse oder Nachweiß?
Nein, habe ich auch nicht gehabt.
Okay.
Mussten Sie sich erbrechen?
Nein.
Okay.
Haben Sie Probleme, eins zu schlafen oder durchzuschlafen?
Hab ich auch kein Problem.
Okay.
Haben Sie in den letzten Seinen zum Beispiel in sechs Monaten
ungewollt ab- oder zugenommen?
Nein, eigentlich bin ich stabil.
Nicht stabil, oder?
Stabil.
Ja, stabil.
Genau.
Ich habe auch nicht die Frage,
ob ich mich nicht stammig bin.
Ich bin nicht stabil, oder?
Ich stabe wie.
Ja, stabil.
Ja, Sie haben gesagt, nur Sie sind ein bisschen fibrig.
Ja, ich konnte nicht das Fibre bezeichnen,
aber das warme Gefühl war.
Ich habe es nicht gemessen.
Ja, okay.
Okay.
Okay, ist bei Ihnen übel?
Okay, übel ist auch nicht.
Okay, Herr Müller, wie Sie schon gesagt haben, Sie eine COPD haben, seit wann haben Sie diese Erkrankungen?
Seit ungefähr zehn Jahren.
Außer diese Krankheiten haben Sie noch andere Vorerkrankungen?
Nein.
Das reicht das aus.
Ja, ja, ich weiß.
Und wurden Sie schon einmal operiert?
Auch nicht, Gott sei Dank.
Ja, das freut mich.
Und was nehmen Sie für COPD ein?
Da gibt es zwei Sprähe, da gibt es zwei Sprähe, die ich von meinen Pognologen bekommen habe.
Und ab und zu natürlich, wenn das stark wird, die geben wir so einen Cortison auch bei Schuwa.
Aber mein Arzt ist aktuell im Urlaub.
Und ich könnte mit ihm nicht Kontakt aufnehmen, um nachzufragen, ob das eine COPD-Bedingung ist,
ob das ein Problem ist oder etwas anderes.
Deswegen bin ich hier gekommen.
Sie haben zwei Sprähe angenommen?
Ja, das ist eine Daur Haft, die ich zu nehmen habe.
Ja, ja, wie ich sie richtig verstanden habe, Sie haben nicht regelmäßig dieses Einzelnen.
Ja, weil ich brauche es nicht öfter.
Ja, manchmal ist es mir schlechter, wenn ich schrauche,
mich schlechte im Sinne von nicht, dass ich Schuwa habe,
sondern auch durch den Luft, durch den Atem, ist es mir schwer.
Daher muss ich meine Sprähe benutzen.
Ich schrauche noch dazu, muss sie eigentlich sein,
sondern 5 bis 6 Sekret pro Tag.
Ich war schon richtig chronisch abus, mit der Tabak sozusagen,
aber ich habe es stark reduziert.
Ich hatte vorher immer über 20 Sekret geraucht.
Seit ungefähr 10 Jahren, ich habe es reduziert,
seit ich das mitbekommen habe,
dass ich meine Lungen schon stark belastet habe.
Das OP ist auch jetzt unter Kontrolle, muss ich sagen,
soweit ich gehe auf, dass ich Kontrolle, Lungen, Atemtest,
macht meine Arzt auch regelmäßig,
der meint, dass wir sind im guter Weg.
Herr Müller, ich empfehle Ihnen,
dass Sie Ihre Sprähe oder Ihre Medikamente
regelmäßig einnehmen müssen.
Okay.
Reagieren Sie allergisch mit Medikamente oder Lebensmittel?
Nein.
Sind Sie vollständig gegen Corona-Virus geimpft?
Ja, ich bin dreimal geimpft.
Und waren Sie schon einmal im Ausland?
Nein, nicht jetzt, vor allem in der letzten Zeit.
Sie haben gesagt, Sie haben 10 Sekrette pro Tag gebraucht.
Ich habe gesagt, dass ich aktuell 5 bis 6 pro Tag.
Ja, 5 bis 6.
Aber früher?
Mehr als 20.
Aber seit 10 Jahren habe ich sie stark kritisiert.
Vor 10 Jahren war das, aber seitdem ich das Diagnose mitbekommen habe,
habe ich sie stark kritisiert.
Und früher, vor 10 Jahren,
wie viele Sekrette brauchen Sie?
20 Sekrette haben Sie?
Wie lange habe ich denn stark geraucht?
Ungefähr 20 Jahre.
Mehr als 20 Sekrette?
Ja, genau.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Herr Müller?
Hallo?
Noch da?
Ich höre Sie ganz schlecht.
Hallo?
Trinken Sie Alkohol, Herr Müller?
Nein, ab und zu.
Das ist eine Rückkinderpräge.
Ich habe das Fragen.
Nehmen Sie Drogen?
Auch nicht mehr.
Okay.
Herr Müller,
oder besuchen Sie regelmäßig in Ihren Hausarzt
um Ihre Versorgung und Untersuchung zu machen?
Was meinst du, damit habe ich genau auch gestern verstanden?
Ja, haben Sie regelmäßig Versorgung und Untersuchung gemacht?
Ich meine, um eine Darmkrebs zu schließen,
auszuschließen, oder?
Okay, das hat mich keiner was gesagt,
ob ich eine Vorsorgeuntersuchung machen muss natürlich.
Ich habe vor 10 Jahren mal einen Darmspiegeln gehabt.
Das war okay, und die meint das jetzt,
ich brauche es aktuell nicht.
Ich habe auch kein Problem mit dem Stuhlgang.
Wie kommen Sie auf die Idee, dass ich das machen muss?
Oder empfinden Sie mich, dass ich das machen muss?
Ja, ab 15 Jahren,
kann man für jede Mensch
oder jede Person Versorgung und Untersuchung machen?
Anbieten, okay.
Ja, und ich würde Ihnen empfehlen auch.
Okay, gerne.
Das würde ich, wenn ich jetzt mit diesen Probleme,
sozusagen, in die Probleme, sich beseitigt,
natürlich würde ich, wenn Sie mich darum kümmern,
würde ich mal in meine Haushalts gehen
und dann würde ich Ihren entsprechenden Untersuchung wahrnehmen.
Danke für Ihre Empfehlung.
Und leben Ihre Eltern noch?
Nee.
Und woran sind Sie gestorben?
Mein Vater hat Lumenkrebs.
Er ist fast vor 10 Jahren verschlafen.
Und meine Mutter hat auch Brustkrebs.
Und in welcher Alter ist sie gestorben?
Sind Sie verstorben?
Ja, das war, mein Vater war schon ungefähr 75 Jahre alt.
Ja.
Und meine Mutter war 70 Jahre alt.
70.
Okay, danke.
Und haben Sie Geschwister?
Nee, habe ich keine.
Und Herr Müller, sind Sie verheiratet?
Auch nicht.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Auch keine Kinder.
Und mit wem wohnen Sie?
Ich wohn alleine, in Gebäude, wo meine Eltern waren.
Ich wohn jetzt da drinnen.
Und was machen Sie beruflich?
Sind Sie beruflich?
Ich bin jetzt durch den COPD schon früher in Rente gegangen.
Und ich war eher so wie Hausmeister, ja, jahrelang.
Und am Ende habe ich alles abgegeben.
Könnte ich nicht mehr.
Okay, Herr Müller, ich denke,
ihr habt alle wirklich eine Frage gestellt.
Haben Sie noch Fragen oder möchten Sie etwas mehr zugeben?
Ich würde gerne wissen, was ich habe, was ich noch zu tun.
Und was würden Sie mich empfehlen, das ist meine Wunsch zur Saison.
Sonst habe ich keine Frage.
Ja, okay.
Herr Müller, ich habe eine Verdacht auf Ihre Lungen erzündet.
Ich vermute, dass Sie eine dünne Entzündung haben.
Ja, ja.
Aber es muss bestätigt werden.
So erst möchte ich Sie körperlich untersuchen.
Danach werde ich bei Ihnen Blut abnehmen.
Und eine Röntgen wird, eine Röntgen Torax,
muss veranlasen werden.
Und jetzt werde ich mit dem Oberarzt sprechen,
wie wir weiter vorgehen.
Danach sprechen wir weiter.
Alles klar.
Danke schön.
Bis gleich.
Haben wir alle Fragen gestellt?
Haben wir etwas vergessen?
Ja, manchmal einige Fragen vergessen.
Haben Sie bei der Diagnostik ein Medikament oder eine Neutropyrat eingenehm?
Nein.
Haben Sie Schulukbechirat oder Öftedogpilenin geholfen?
Ja, das ist aber nicht neu.
Ich habe es von der Brille ab und zu gehabt seit Jahren lang.
Aber jetzt mit diesen Problemen, mit diesen Beschwerden,
hat sich das nicht verändert oder geändert.
Die Probleme für sich sind nicht zunehmend.
Ich habe Fragen, aber Sie haben Antwort.
Hatten Sie so jetzt das für Sie schon einen Mann?
Nein.
Diese Maß habe ich gesagt, habe ich nie gehabt.
Deswegen habe ich gesagt, ich kann nicht jetzt lange warten.
Bei einer Behandlung Arzt ist es ein Mulaub.
Ich muss jetzt in den Krankenhaus, dass ich das klären lassen, warum ich es habe.
Wie haben Sie sich die Beschwerden mit der Zeit für drei Tage angesprochen?
Ja, so starker Husten, so ein Druck auf den Brust und Schmerzen noch.
Als ich gesagt habe, wie ich das beschreiben habe,
leichte Temperatur hatte ich auch gehabt.
Da habe ich nicht gemessen, aber so ein leichter Auswurf.
Aber das war immer, wie es war, muss ich sagen.
Deswegen wegen den Husten, da muss man wegen Schmerzen und Schmerzen in den Krankenhaus.
Können Sie vielleicht im Bett liegen?
Geht. Das ist nicht aber neue Probleme von mir.
Das war immer so.
Wie viel Kissen haben Sie?
Ich habe ein spezieller Bett, wo ich wegen der Reflukskrankheiten meine,
dass ich etwas hatte, aber nicht ausgeprägt habe.
Ich habe auch aus dem, dass meine Empfehlung von meinem Haus heißt,
dass ich nicht gerade schlafen, sondern auch mit mir ein bisschen flächern,
so zu sagen, so ein Zehn- oder 15-Gerat.
Momentan, was steht im Vordergrund,
Beliefnot oder das Türkei für den Brusten?
Druck, Gefühlen, Schmerzen mit Husten.
Das war es. Dankeschön.
Haben noch andere Fragen, Kollegen?
Ob die anderen Kollegen Fragen haben.
Können Sie einfach Luft kriegen?
Noch ein paar Werte, ich herrsch nicht.
Luftnot.
Haben Sie auch Luftnot?
Und dritten Bespieler, in der Nacht?
Oder Tagsüber und nach?
Luftnot habe ich.
Das wurde nicht genau gefragt.
Aber jetzt müssen Sie vertiefen, wann und wie.
Vielleicht Sie möchten uns fragen,
ist das eine Einatmen-Luftnot?
Oder Ausatmen?
Wieder einatmen, noch im Ausatmen.
Noch?
Noch, bis zu Luftnot, muss ich weiter fragen.
Bis zu Brustschmerzen, das muss noch gefragt werden.
Können wir anfangen?
Nein, muss ich noch fragen.
Ich war von der Gruppe noch die anderen Fragen.
Meinen Sie Brustschmerzen?
Ja, ich habe so einen Brustschmerzen.
Ich habe so eine Druck auf dem Brust,
mit Schwertz und...
Ich habe schon die sieben Dimension gestellt.
Aber vielleicht...
Was man einfach, der einfachste Frage,
was man hier stellen soll,
Belastung, das für mich.
Aber hier habe ich schon gefragt...
Er hat gesagt, im Stehen, hat er nicht gefragt,
ob ich bei Belastung...
Stätten Sie Stehen oder Legen?
Ja, ja.
Das war nicht bei Belastung.
Die Frage war so, haben Sie im Stehen,
im Legen oder im Sitz?
Stätten Sie Bestätten auch in Ruhe
oder nur bei Belastung auf?
Das ist wichtig.
Muss man die Belastung Wort benutzen.
Belastung ist etwas anderes als im Stehen.
Ich stehe, aber ich habe keine Luftnot.
Aber wenn ich so ein paar Schritte laufen,
oder da habe ich so ein vermehrtes Schmerzen,
das muss man auch...
Wer sich das nicht interessiert,
hier hat er gefragt,
ob Sie sich beim Schmerzen
abhängig davon sitzen
oder Legen stehen.
Das ist Laguerung,
Belastung.
Das ist nicht Laguerung,
aber das ist ein Belastung.
Das ist Laguerung,
das ist ein Belastung.
das ist nicht Laguerung,
aber das ist ein Belastung.
Das wurde nicht gefragt.
Ich höre ganz genau.
Weil in den Proven,
die können auch so eine Frage stellen.
Die Unterricht muss man wissen.
Sie haben Laguerung,
das ist nicht Laguerung,
das muss man auch tragen.
Und was noch dazu?
Da muss man noch fragen.
Haben Sie,
ich hole eine Beine,
eine gute Frage,
eine tolle Frage.
Nein.
Warum haben Sie die Frage gestellt?
Ich möchte von Harz 1 zu
Sylton talscheiden.
Sehr gut, noch etwas?
Dann machen wir den dem...
Ja, sehr gut.
Jung und Emily.
Genau.
Deswegen muss man die Frage
immer noch vertiefen.
Und
wie fühlen Sie sich allgemein?
Wie fühlen Sie sich krank
wie Erkältung oder Brepe?
Ich fühle mich
in den letzten 3 Tagen
schwer erkrankt, muss man sagen.
Durch den Husten,
durch den Schmerzen.
So eine Erkältung würde ich nicht sagen.
Das ist eine Erkältung.
Ich habe immer ab und zu
Erkältungen gehabt,
um in dieser Maß Husten zu haben.
Oder
zu erleben,
war nicht so,
muss man sagen.
Haben Sie
selbst
eine Corona-Schnelltest
durchgeführt?
Gute Frage.
Hab ich gemacht.
Das war negativ.
Das ist ein aktuelles
Abtodet, muss man sagen.
Das ist auch richtig.
Bei jeder Husten
muss man Corona testen.
Was wurde nicht gefragt noch?
Bist du
nicht der
Brustschmelzen?
Genau,
hier hat
Brücken.
Genau.
Aber
wie sieht es aus mit der Belastung?
Haben wir gefragt best?
Ist es vermehrt mit der Belastung
oder nicht?
Wie viele Treppen steigen?
Wie viele Treppen
steigen bevor sie
stehen bleiben
oder Luftnot haben?
Wie viele
schaffen sie?
Wie viele Tage schaffen sie?
Nach der 1.
Tage bin ich fix und fertig.
Oder ohne Pause
zu machen?
Ja, nach der 1.
Tage.
Ich habe das
maximal seit 3 Tagen nicht mehr.
Okay,
ich bespreche den Arzt.
Bitte schön.
Guten Tag Herr Oberarztin.
Haben Sie Zeit für mich?
Ja, schon guten Tag.
Ich möchte Ihnen
über einen neuen Patient
berichten.
Ja,
ich möchte Ihnen
über einen neuen Patient
berichten.
Herr Schmidmüller
ist 65 Jahre Patientin
und
1,70 m
groß und 80 kg schwer.
Er
erstaute sich
wegen
seit
4 Tagen
bestehenden
und
zunehmenden
Erstaunen
und
mit
leichtem Auswurf
für
die Schmerzen
sein
ohne Ausstrahlung
aufgetreten
und
erklagt
über
die Büsbne
und Belastung
abhängig.
Sie können
nur
eine Etage einsteigen.
Auserden
gab er
auch an
die Schmerzen
nicht
dauerhaft
sein.
Die Fragen
nach
der Schmerz-Serie
die Fragen nach
geschwollener Bein
Lagerung abhängig
Atemabhängig
wurde verneint.
Die Schmerzintensität
sein
während Husten
7, 8
und
ohne Husten
4, 5
liegen.
Schmerzskala
Die
bis auf
Fieber
sei die vegetative Anamnese
unauffällig
die Patienten
leiden
seit
10 Jahren
COPD
und dagegen
eine Sphäre
angenommen
erwähnte
er
er nehme
nicht regelmäßig ein
allergin
sein
bei ihm nicht bekannt
und
er
wurde keine
Operation
operiert
er wurde nicht operiert
hatte keine OP gehabt
ja, er hatte
keine OP gehabt
und
er sei wegen Corona
vollständig geimpft
Tabakabusus
oder
er rauka
seit 10 Jahren
50 Zigaretten täglich
aber früher
Backups
wurde Tabakabusus
mit 20 Backups
beiat
Alkohol, Konsum
und Drogenabusus
wurden verneint
in der Familienanamnese
ergab sich
Torax
oder
langen Karcinum
Beinfatte
und
Mama Karcinum
Beidenmutter
er sei Lady und habe keine Kinder
allein
er lebe allein
er sei Räbner
und früher
früher
habe er Hausmeister
von Beruf
die Vegetativen
früher als
als Hausmeister
ja, früher habe er
gearbeitet
ja, die Vegetativen
ja
die Anamnese
deuten am ersten
auf
akute Pynomony
hin
und die Vegetativen
ja, als Differenzial Diagnosen
kommen
ja, Lungenembore
und
ja
ja, Lungenkrebs
auch
vielleicht
ja, Bronchial Karcinum
im Betracht
so weiter
wurde
oder um die Verdacht Diagnose
zu bestätigen
sollten wir
die weitere Diagnostischen
Massnahmen durchführen
ja,
rundken Torax
Blutbild
wie
so wie
Gerinnungsparameter
ja
Entsündungparameter
Lebewerte
und Nierenwerte
sehr gut
Was würden Sie als erstes
machen in diesem Fall
wenn Sie eine Patient haben
jetzt in der Notaufnahme
bekannte COPD
das würde ich als erstes denken
als erstes denken
oder ja
als erstes, dass die Patient hat
bekannte COPD und seit 3 Tagen
sie nehmen Probleme
mit Husten
und drüber auf den Brust
und was würden Sie denken, als erstes
das ist eine neue Attac
oder eine Schubung
eine akute Schubung
eine akute Schub
von COPD
erstes mal, das ist wichtig
aber man fragt sich
3 Tage zu niemenden
Könnte sein
aber es ist nicht verkehrt, da haben Sie Frau Recht
Was könnte noch sein, das so
Was würden Sie
Sie machen jetzt Diagnostik
ja
Covid jetzt Spallung
super Kollegen, Covid ist getestet
ist negativ
ja, außer Covid
kann man
auch
Panamoni
auch denken
und
vielleicht zum Ausschluss
für Herzinfarkt
oder Myocardinfarkt
sind EKG
und Cardiac
Enzymen
Notpendi
Vollrecht
wir kommen noch auf den
aber Sie machen es gut
als Sie gesagt haben, wir reden
erst mal um unsere
Wahrscheinlichkeit
eine Hochwahrscheinlichkeit
von der Krankenzulandung
Sie haben gesagt
eine Erschubung von COPD
richtig
und Lungenentzündung, Panamoni
ist auch richtig, Könnte sein
davor machen Sie dann
Grundkanauffnahmen
Entzündung, Parameter
wenn Sie eine COPD und Lungen,
Sie haben die Vermutung,
Was würden Sie noch machen?
Ja
geringes Parameter, inklusive
DEDIMA
wir reden über
Lungenentzündung und COPD
Was würden Sie machen?
Was sind Sie
vor Ihnen
und Sie sehen den Zustand
dass er
Starkuszen hat
Man kann auch
die Zutatsanalyse
sehr wichtig
aber davor brauchen Sie auch
ich würde in so einem Basin
auch ein Nudaufnahme
zur ersten Kreislauf mal schicken
Sauerstoff
und ein Monitor
genau
man braucht bei jeder
Nudfallpassion
das ist dann erstes Schritt
ansonsten können Sie nicht weiter kommen
wenn Sie das von 100 haben
100%
dann sind Sie beruhigt
wenn das Patient hat gute Sauerstoff
dann kann ich der Rest langsam und ruhig machen
wenn Sie das
übersehen
wenn der Patient eine heilste Rhythmus von 130 hat
und das übersehen Sie
dann sehen Sie das nicht
der Rest, was Sie machen ist umsonst
weil der Patient geht in den nächsten
in den Kardial
die Kompensation
das ist ein Problem
das heißt die 3 Sachen bei jeder Patient
auch in der Praxis messen
das ist eine Standard Goldmaßdauer
und dann
der nächstes BGH
dann können Sie auch in Ruhe machen
dann können Sie auch in Sauerstoff
mit Trotz BGH
wie das passt
für die Lungeninzinnung
wenn Sie das nicht machen
kriegen Sie das Geld nicht von der Kasse
weil die brauchen das
weil Sie auch COPD
wie nur so
das spielt keine Rolle
Sie brauchen eine BGH
sehr gut
wegen der COPD
haben wir 2 Kleinigkeiten
die machen können
nur das machen ist gemacht
Sie vermuten das könnte auch in der Lungenimbuli sein
oder?
ja
eigentlich die Analystik
richtig
sich nach dem Lungenimbuli
als Schub von der COPD
weil seit 3 Tagen
das zu nehmen
das ist ein akut Ereignis
das ist nicht chronisch
der Mann sagt klar
seit 10 Jahren leide ich nur
unter einer COPD
aber so eine Probleme habe ich nie gehabt
das ist die ausgeprägte Symptome
das ihr noch nie erlebt habt
wenn er so beschreibt
da muss man ernst nehmen
seit 3 Tagen
das könnte man auch etwas vertiefen
die Frage
vor 3 Tagen wurde er plötzlich aufgetreten
oder langsam
das haben wir auch nicht gefragt
das muss man auffragen
ist es plötzlich aufgetreten
oder ist es schon mal langsam
und in den letzten 2 Tagen ist es noch schlimmer geworden
das ist auch wichtig für unser Diagnostik
ist das zu sagen
Verfahren
wenn er sagt das plötzlich aufgetreten
dann ist es schon klar
dann ist es Lungenimbuli
kann nicht anders sein
dann geht es von dieser Richtung
und dann mache ich weiter an
okay, Sie vermuten, dass es Lungenimbuli ist
und was machen Sie denn
ich würde
die mal
überprüfen
das kann man machen
das ist auch nicht verkehrt
ich würde
sollte sich die Verdacht
zu bestätigen
würde ich
Antikovolgiterapie mit der Parin
würde ich sofort
bei Erhälter
die die mehr eine antikovolgiterapie starten
oder machen Sie noch
das ist der Durstin
fast ich
die Diagnose
bestätigen
mit was würden Sie das machen denn
Sie haben eine Vermutung
die Verdacht Diagnosis
die Lungenimbuli
Sie haben BGA gemacht
Sie haben Didyama gemacht
Didyama ist auch BGA
ist auch im Grenz, das geht
braucht nicht starker Unterstützung
was würden Sie noch machen
die Diagnose zu bestätigen
ja MRT
nein
Röntgen Torax hat denn eingeschrieben
aber Röntgen Torax kann man machen
damit kann man
eine Atopyspneumonie
oder eine COPD
nicht ausschließen
sondern etwas bestätigen
der Lungenimbuli
aber kann man nicht
Mittel einer Rücken
in der Lungenimbuli ausschließen
was braucht man dafür
sehr gut, Kollegen schreibt ein CT
was für CT braucht man
Torax CT
muss das so
Centigrafe
Nein
Angesetze
das muss spezial geschrieben werden
wenn Sie eine normale
Torax CT machen
Sie werden
eine große Lungenimbuli
damit ausschließen
aber wenn Sie eine Prefere, kleine Lungenimbuli haben
Sie brauchen
unbedingt eine Pulmonalangesetze
Mittel einer Pulmonalangesetze
die können Sie auch in der
Prefere Lungenimbuli ausschließen
das ist eine Großstandard
wenn Sie so etwas haben
dann müssen Sie das machen
wenn das COPD
wenn die D-Dema
hoch ist
wenn die Kinder
sich nach der Pulmonalangbuli
dann müssen Sie das machen
Was würden Sie noch machen
wenn Sie jetzt sagen
eine Lungenimbuli ist
man macht sofort CT
oder dafür macht man etwas anders
in der Notaufnahme
kann sich sehr gut
ECHO schreibt man
ECHO macht dann auch Standards
warum macht man das
Ja um eine
Herzprobleme oder Herzkrankheiten
ausschließen
Nein
Rechtheisbelastung
sehr gut schreibt die Kollegen
während der Lungenimbuli
Rechtheisbelastung
wir testen Sie nicht
dass Sie falsch verstehen
es geht um dass wir unseres
sozusagen Ketten tauschen
davor machen wir dieser
Gespräch jetzt
das ist eine Standard
wenn Sie eine Lungenimbuli haben
Sie haben eine Rechtheisbelastung
aber nicht bei jeder Lungenimbuli
wenn Sie nur per Ferlung in der Muli haben
Sie werden keine Rechtheisbelastung haben
UnkG wird unauffällig
wenn Sie eine Zentralung in der Muli haben
dann können Sie eine Rechtheisbelastung haben
dann sehen Sie das in der UnkG
und sagen Sie, der Mann hat eine Rechtheisbelastung
Mensch sagt, ich brauche keine Siti
das ist schon klar, der hat Rechtheisbelastung
Mensch, gerade die Lungen
und das ist Hinweis auf eine Lungenimbuli
eine Staatsschmidtante-Kokulation, Punkt Schluss
fertig
wenn man so sicher ist
aber meines Erachtens ist besser
dass man in der Pulminale Angest durchzuführen
dass es besser für die Patienten
ist, dass sie das ausgeschliesst haben
erhöhte Pulminale Altaferendruck
das sieht man auch in den E-Cro
haben Sie vorwicht
aber
wichtiges Sache für die Prüfung
das heißt, sie brauchen eine
weil Lungenimbuli, sie brauchen eine
Notaufnahme BGH
die dem Hersteltaschein
dann, der Rest, es außerhalb der Notaufnahme
zum CT müssen sie in der Radiologie schicken
und man macht es am meisten so
dass man sagt, ich nehme den Patient auf
ob es CT der geht auf Station
praktisch
der Patient ist gut versorgt
hat alles bekommen und dann geht auf Station
oder können Sie wieder eine Notaufnahme
bestellen
das geht auch aber mindestens
das außerhalb der Notaufnahme
dann ist es auch gemacht CT
und hat sich mit der Medellung
im Bilümbulibisch gestorben
und Sie haben vorhin klar gesagt
dass Sie mit einer Antikokulation starten
welche Antikokulation
würden Sie jetzt
ja, Heparin
ja, das ist eine Standard
das macht eine Notaufnahme
sondern nicht die Molekule
Heparin einfach
wie dosiert man, kennt sie
ich habe mit aus oder ja nicht
dass sie je nach Gewicht zu sagen
Gewicht adaptiert der Dosierung
ja, sie sind ein bisschen
in der Prozung
da müssen Sie lesen
das ist aber nicht so schwer
vielleicht in der Prozung die Fragen weißt du nicht genau
aber müssen Sie wissen auch wahrscheinlich
bei Heparin ja
aber bei Nord
müssen Sie nicht unbedingt
wenn Sie nur einfach sagen, ja sofort
mit Nord auch gestatten, das geht auch
aber Central mit Heparin ist man
und dann Umstellung auf Nord
das ist besser
und dann man gibt
das Monat sagt man ja
maximal 3 Monate
und bis jetzt Monat kann man das machen
und was würde man noch machen
wenn Sie jetzt in der Lungeninobilie bestätigt haben
vorhin der Kollegen hat auch gefragt
wegen Beine
Udema habe ich nicht
das würden Sie noch machen
eine EKG schreiben
EKG, das muss man sowieso machen
das ist schon eine Standard
das gehört auch dazu
auch so eine Hälste
während der Lungeninobilie
gegen die Hälsrasen
vorflimmen man
das gehört auch dazu
da sehen Sie auch ab und zu
das muss man nicht, aber kann man auch haben
das schreiben die Kollegen
die Kollegen, die schreiben doppelere Beine
doppelere, das ist wichtig, das muss man machen
damit man
aber wenn der Patient
eine Beine Udema hat
muss nicht
trotzdem gehört das so
Patient hat keine starke Beine Udema
hat trotzdem oben in einem großen Gefäß
eine Thrombose
die Durchblutung ist normal
aber der hat Thrombose jetzt dort
und die schießt nach oben
das können Sie nicht sagen
der hat Durchblutung, normal Durchblutung
im Wein, aber
hat trotzdem Thrombose
ja auch umgekehrt
könnte auch sein, haben Sie recht
das ist der starke Udema hat
haben Sie nicht entschieden würde ich
doppler machen
weil er einen klarer Txt hat
aber dann hat man nicht Beidseite
dann hat man eine Seite die machen
dann ist schon klar, weil sieht man den Unterschied
wo die Thrombose ist
das wäre mehr
Udematose als anderen Beinen
okay
wenn man Beidseite hat
es ist eher so ein Kardialproblem
man sagt man ist nicht primonial
es sind Kardialprobleme
es könnte auch schon sein
dass Sie eine hessische
Städtelung in den Bully bekommen
während des dessen
haben Sie eine unterschänkende Idee
das könnte schon sein
kann auch auftreten
aber das kann nicht eine Ausschlussdiagnose
oder von der TVT sein
muss man trotzdem machen
und was würden Sie noch machen
warum der Mann hat den Lungen im Bully
es kann sein
ja mit Problemen
das ist ja auch bei den Gerinnungsparametern
ja
man kann das auch denken
es kann hematologisch ein Problem hinterher sein
aber man sieht
das Gerinnung ist normal
Thrombosunzahl ist normal
hat keine Blutung
Geschichte
ja sie rauchten
schon lange
und man nicht
er rauchte
natürlich jahrelang
da muss man eine Melignität
auch damit ausschließen
in diesem Alter wenn man stark geraucht hat
jetzt nebenbei COPD
man kann auch
Brunschescopie veranlassen
und braucht man nicht Brunschescopie
oder ein CT
Sie haben eine CT gemacht
mit der CT können Sie die Lungen
genau sehen ob den Krebs hat
oder nicht
aber man braucht eine Ultrasche noch dass du
es könnte sein dass es
ein Problem ist
dass man ein Lymphknot in den Bauch sieht
damit man
kann man nicht ausschließen
aber hinweist auf ein Darmproblem
oder Marnproblem
man macht so eine Standorteilung
eine Abdomenultrasche
und was noch dazu
wie Sie vorhin erwähnt haben
eine Vorsorgeuntersuchung
dann geht man Richtung Marnenspiegelung
Darmspiegelung
wenn man Lungenembole hat
mit der Armkrebs
mit der Dissen kann man die Beine ausschließen
und die Kollegin schreibt
sehr gut Reiser
wurde auch gefragt
ob ich gereist habe
oder nicht
das ist auch so lang
wenn man
lange Reise hat
dann kriegt man auch
das ist auch wieder TVT
das kommt nicht von sich allein
dann kriegt man TVT
ansonsten
wir haben alles gefragt
und alle Diagnostik durchgeführt
haben wir etwas vergessen
Immobilität
das könnte man auch fragen
aber
ich denke
seit langem
habe er
oder sei er
Immobil
wenn man Immobil ist, dann ist es richtig
aber der Mann kommt
und die Diagnostik
aber sie haben voll Recht
muss man fragen
vermuten kann man vieles
aber
wenn man auf Deutsch schreibt
man muss in dem Sinne fragen
weil sie nicht gefragt haben
mit der Vermutung
die Nachvollstehung
zuerst wollte ich fragen
treiben Sie Sport
oder sehr gut
aber dann habe ich
gedacht, dass es sinnvoll ist
weil
sie haben
die Leider
an COPD
und sie haben starke Brustschmerzen
und
ich dachte selber
er
ist sein Immobil
ja, aber trotzdem
für jede Gruppe gibt es
eine spezielle Sport
vor COPD gibt es auch Sport
vor Krebs
von Ottwilch
gibt es auch Sport
da muss man Sport
haben, da gibt es keine Grenze
ja
dann muss man ein Bett legere
dann kriegt man auch Sport
passiv Sport kriegt man auch
Konfysiotherapie kriegt man das
bis zum Ende, genau wie ihr
wartet, kann man ohne Ende machen
das ist auch so ohne Ende, da gibt es keine Grenze
aber gute Frage
ich glaube
Differentialdiagnose haben wir
auch selbst
gesprochen
London Krebs auch
HES Probleme
haben wir UKG gemacht
noch dazu, LKG gemacht
das wurde auch gemacht
und was braucht man noch
natürlich bei Lungen
im Bully braucht man nicht Luft
aber wenn man sagt es cover keine Lungen
dann braucht man auch Luft hoch
das ist ein Atemtest
dass man der Lungenkapazität
genau schätzt
und sieht
nicht dass es doch in der COPD
schupe ist
dafür braucht man
den Atemobungen
da kriegt man auf Station
mit seinem Gerät
das werden sie dann später auf Station
lagen, falls sie dahin kommen
oder falls sie an STC machen
da müssen sie sowieso dann lernen
ansonsten
wir haben alles gesprochen
und Krebs Geschichte
in ihren Alten
ist auch wichtig
genau
und Vorsorge
untersuchen durch das
bei Frauen ist der Risikofaktor
die ganze Sache
bei Männer, viele kommen nicht in die Pfarrer
aber OP und so weiter
haben sie auch gefragt weil ich keine gehabt
sie haben einen tollen gemacht
haben wir etwas vergessen
vielleicht
in Aktuellen
haben alle etwas gelernt
oder gefragt
allergie
ja allergie wurde auch gefragt
das ist eine Schub sein
das wurde gefragt
habe ich keine
das könnte auch sein
aber plötzlich
könnte alles möglich sein
ich habe extra COPD gesagt
weil am meisten
unterschätzt man den der Lungenembolie
bei chronischer Hess
Krankheiten und bei COPD
leider
und daraufhin habe ich extra
diese Fragen bestellt
dass man nicht unterschätzen soll
dass man auch
nebenbei so etwas auch denken
zu sagen
haben wir etwas vergessen
ich glaube nicht
wenn sie keine mehr Fragen haben
dann sind wir fertig oder